[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima we are here
at the i go live app launch event and i
gotta tell you it was a night of
kardashian exes lamar odom tyga blac
chyna we talked to a mom you look great
let me just ask you you know you have
you been through a lot lately but how
are you doing I'm doing good I'm doing
good I'm just feeling blessed right now
but things turned a bit bizarre inside
the bash when Rob Kardashian's ex blac
Chyna hung out and posed for photos with
Khloe Kardashian's ex-husband Lamar Odom
the run-in comes just weeks after Odom
told ET he's praying for Rob amid his
relationship drama you got this tell-all
book you're working on are people gonna
be upset you're gonna tell all in this
book people will be gonna be eye-opening
for everybody so you talked about the
Kardashians of the mother yeah
and the good way though when was the
last time you talked to any of them was
in my heart meanwhile X's China and Tyga
opened up about raising their
four-year-old son how are things going
in your co-parenting situation everybody
loves little King he's so cute great
better than ever I got an amazing son
I'm blessed
he's the best man honestly like he's you
know he's such a blessing
China's supposed to be here tonight how
are things with you guys oh we good we
go ya know for sure we're good we have
we have a baby together you know Yeah
right you've been through a lot with the
Kardashians how is your relationship
with the family I mean I'm good yeah
well what's next for you just being
positive and you know working on my
brand and lashed an 88 pin that's really
all I can do right now and being a good
mother of course
[Music]